Merry Christmas everybody and Happy
Holidays and I really see little song be
merry christmas everybody from provider
and the killaby to a beat
merry christmas everybody we're not
taking any prisoners next year well no
prisoners Christmas doesn't do for me
gonna go on testosterone probably in
about 4 months where I'm 51 you're never
gonna get my stupid little background
music do we have any back and pull up
bring up a Christmas song for sure so
last one we're going dark next week
we're going dark guys we're going dark
we're taking a week off Brian's going
black face yeah I gotta go to it con
[ __ ] I have Cancun guys no I'm cool
you're not into Cancun no I'm not so
good at no Orange County you're right
how do you want that chestnuts roasting
on an open fire
no it's roasting well I like then find a
bigger dick than Buble I don't know
others me why so smarmy I don't know let
me hear it
I don't know me they're just it's the
last five kids a year y'all it's been a
good year
it sure has Brett it sure has man I have
to wind it down talk about a couple nuts
about nuts that hang low like chestnuts
I get you're not you know what I mean
yeah this one goes out to all you guys
out there I want to thank all of you for
listening and being so loyal
hey Buble let us take this one how you
[ __ ] let me get the karaoke version hey
Buble nice round out the karaoke version
great idea oh yes but there's no lyrics
on this one oh you neither you know
speaking of roasting nuts you're right
buddy
I love roasting nuts you're not saying
lo they do and on this you know what I
want for the fans this Christmas party
what everyone a bus tonight you know
what I like to do on a Christmas morning
to come down with my row of nothing
underneath no my legs open so my
children and the wife and everybody else
can see my three-piece lazy and dirty
said although somehow sitting on the
fabric of the chair you talking about
giving ruin that baby bird is good and
everybody goes oh come on I go not come
on this one's for you guys yes these
nuts because we youth family and I look
at my kids and I go thank my nuts
because because of these saggy old dirty
dirty of this dirty sack you guys are
walking the earth I feel the same thing
I say the same thing I walked down I got
my peace out I said these nuts are the
gift that keeps on giving you're right
buddy and guess what what I know what
you're gonna say this Christmas my thank
my nuts for your kids I mean if you like
its worst my nuts what'd I say well that
says you know what everyone's getting
this Christmas what's at Dee's these
Jesus yeah you know what buddy that's a
great way to put it hey Family Worship
munoz cuz if it wasn't for nuts you
wouldn't be here you wouldn't be happy
you liked all these gifts mhm nuts paid
for these hmm I got some stray hairs on
him this the hair grows and no apparent
order it's just some of its white some
of its gray some of its actually been
sitting between my leg and my Emma sack
for so long that it's actually beginning
to disintegrate it doesn't even look
like hair it looks like a synthetic
threat yeah it almost looks like you see
we that's right yeah that's right
I got strange bumps on it probably
barnacles could be Warriors could be
skint at its what down a weird road and
it sure did by the way we run worship
our nuts yeah that's that's really a
theme of this that's right
and [ __ ] you Buble [ __ ] you how about
that chestnuts roasting on an open fire
I don't know can you get me the words
we'd like to sing this for you guys
we're gonna sing this for you I'm gonna
sing it hard you know well you're what
you're listening listen you're pricing
around your dinner table I just want you
to ball your hand up in a tight tight
fist and then run your [ __ ] face
right into why would they do give
yourself a black eye for Christmas it's
for Christmas
you know what Brennan you know what
should we hit it let's hit it
one and A two and A three and a foot
here chestnuts roasting on an open fire
Jack Frost nipping at your nose Yuletide
Carol's being sung by a choir and folks
dressed up like Eskimos correct let's
call him you picker Inuits
everybody knows a turkey and some
mistletoe help to make the season bright
tiny tots with their eyes all of Oh will
find it hard to sleep tonight they know
Santa's on his way he's loaded lots of
toys and goodies on his sleigh and every
mother's child is going to be spy to see
the reindeer really know how to fly and
so I'm offering this simple phrase to
kids from one to ninety-two although
it's been said many times merry
Christmas to you and so I'm offering
this simple phrase to kids from one to
ninety-two although there is one more
time
Wow man we really hit it buddy I love
you pal
hey Christmas you filthy animal
Christmas to you you filthy animal well
I just I just copied you repeated what I
said there
want you to take your question cup your
hand I want you to let me sit my balls
in it and I want you to thank my balls
my ball I want you to get your
liver-spotted hands on this dick for
Christmas I can't do that bro my hands
are calloused and why would you want
that I thought you liked girls you know
what I want for Christmas Indian rug
burn with your liver hands on my dick
all right
hmm give me an Indian rug burn I'm a
domme also known as a [ __ ] right I
tell bro and jobs are the worshop I met
one girl once who gave me a good hand
job once I was like she's the only girl
I was like haha [ __ ] you you're you're
better than I am it's almost alarming if
the to get out that's the head the
practice what's doing it in a way we're
like there's a difference between
yanking and actually feeling like she
was feeling it she was enjoying she's
molding play oh man yeah I was like
touch mo cuz most girls ought to grab it
too har they started yanking on my hey
man it's not a motorbike yeah and you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're doing
cuz I know I've been doing this let me
get on this sure Brogan just have this
joke where I'd be like girl starts
jerking you off and you're like what
makes you possibly think that you could
be better I'm gonna trenches every
[ __ ] day dude last night at the
Comedy Store rogue Inc hey that everyone
the whole place is good good good good
good good good good good
I told you I followed Dane Cook and I
really enjoyed watching him I said he'll
hot guest Thank You Farley crack me up I
haven't seen him in a while and I was
watching him and I was like just
enjoying you know and you forget you're
like oh yeah he's come to the hook yeah
he's been doing it he's [ __ ] great at
it and he just crack me up speaks the
language hood crowd at The Improv be
there tonight so will you possibly
depending Lee I know you're feeling a
little under the weather so I'm not
looking to the weather man I'm gonna
stick it for thermometer right up your
[ __ ] oh I'm gonna get a correct read
on your butt on your temperature and if
it if it's even a little high I'm tuck
you in please
give you I'm gonna give you a a glass of
warm milk and roasted with a mouthful of
[ __ ] honey
and you're gonna yep you're gonna sip
that milk well I will I put a warm towel
on your forehead I'm gonna go there nice
yep and as I and I'm gonna and then I'm
gonna go like this I'm gonna go poop my
dick and your balls I'm gonna go I'm
gonna squeeze them with my fingertips
I'm gonna go OOP OOP that's right you
know why this heaven
yep that's to check to make sure
everything is is working and I'm also
gonna give you an anal scrape now what
is an anal spray listening relax I take
my index finger and I and I and I run it
across your anus to see if your Anas
puckers that that can show good nerve
good health and good nervous but easier
good reflex response I get I get a
bonded friendship with my friend alright
so there it is okay then and then as a
final tuck in before I go do my set I'm
gonna [ __ ] you right up you're American
Hey Wow yep yeah that's right no man I'm
not going well how do I set with a full
a full sack I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ]
dude empty out too much do you know what
this is a cross live yes this is funny
you talking about emptying your stack on
my face that's right Harry Connick jr.
I'm gonna out him for a second I was
talking he's so funny we used to be
pretty close now at his house for a
Christmas party and he was talking to
the guy I didn't know and Harry just was
Harry could be so much devious and I'm
talking to the guy and and it said
Brian's a comic and he's one of the
funniest guys in the world and goes oh
that's great and Harry without
hesitation goes and he can take you can
take her hey you can take a rose stem it
all and stick it right up his on the
house it was so random he goes he'll
take us a rose stamin Hall and stick it
right up his own ass too I don't know he
was Southern gentleman we were laughing
so hard
yeah you should reach out to him hey
don't kid hey have you got all your
Christmas shopping done I haven't bought
a single present sir not one not a
single present behind one
go with the Christmas thing I just let
my wife do all the work and my in-laws
to all the more than you're surprised
when the kids open them up like dad
thanks for this right oh wow yeah yeah
bought a two hundred dollar pillow from
mr. Pell oh well it's one of those
Posturepedic things differ a little too
hard in my head well too stiff what are
you doing it's it's got the water gel
now what he doing right way too stiff Oh
Sam I [ __ ] up my head's on a [ __ ]
stove I know I know my daughter stole it
sleeping like a rock waking up in a
great mood give give to her now hell no
my sleep my son last night I bought him
a bag he's been jumping on the crib I'm
more impressed than anything with that
but he's jumping out of the crib at 22
months so I'm like you know what that's
dangerous give him a little kid bed
give him the bed and we have this like
like sleep coach or whatever tell us
what to do with the kid yeah she's like
listen he's gonna go berserk in there
make sure you safe the room so baby save
his secrets and then just put a crate so
he can't get out
sure that doesn't sound too bad I've it
looked like a goddamn tornado hit his
room for an hour he literally just like
he was freaking Axl Rose in a hotel room
yeah dude destroyed that thing and was
finally so exhausted after an hour
passed out on the bed he he'll say that
kid is now is he gonna join the seals
next year you can see me you're too
developer I shoulda seen all the [ __ ] it
looked it literally looked like when I
saw his haircut like and he had that
short hair and I was like well the kids
neck goes into his head he's got traps
and he's got meat hooks for him I'd be
Takeo spikes good I don't know man
yeah he's a big boy he's a fake kid
mother surprise I think I'm gonna take
his uh although he doesn't deserve room
take his ass to Disneyland tomorrow the
shop boys are very thick like Jay who I
was talking I'm stakin I'm in Austin I'm
talking about this this guy's like I'm a
strong guy big handsome guy and I was
like what do you weigh you guys you're
really strong huh guys you have strong
about 210 and I see Jay Jay he goes like
this I just say to Jessie J go he just
lifts my eyebrow and he goes like just a
noticeable disapproval
like oh I started laughing so hard yeah
I come I go what do you weigh Jegs about
two-thirty at Lee goes up I'll deadlift
500 pounds right now
you put it on oh yeah geez I was like
geez shaky you think he's got a very
good batteries or but I but I saw him
with his shirt off Lucky's got shitty
posture and he's in a computer he's a
[ __ ]
he lives on snicker bars I didn't give a
[ __ ] he's not a very good but he had a
heart I don't know why I'm laughing at
the tiny scariest [ __ ] but it's good now
he thought he had a heart attack I am
you know I talked to him non-stop
throughout the day yeah family reasons
and business reasons cuz he runs all our
[ __ ] and I didn't hear from it I was
busy till like I [ __ ] heard from so
I'm like hey I'll text him something
like Oh what are you doing dick lips and
he goes that's how we talk to each other
and he goes in the emergency room
[ __ ] I'm like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
what happened I so I called me I
panicked thing he goes man he has sweaty
palms anyways like a gecko all the time
videos my palms were sweating so crazy
driving to work and then my chest got
all tight she goes so I called like this
nurse hotline has a nurse I called this
nurse hotline then I get to the hospital
immediately
er this sounds like you having a heart
attack so he gets there they run all the
tests they didn't find thing with his
heart they said it could have been like
severe severe heartburn sometimes I can
show up where tightness on the chest I
don't know but my dad had then I give
like no have you been eating health and
he goes I've had good times the past 7
days good times like the Burger King in
Denver
like what yeah well you know yeah he'll
he's just sitting there chopping down
Snickers but but not genetics yeah a
[ __ ] very good body yeah tears like
yours oh yeah and and his dong we talked
about this badass room is the sense of
what is I took his dong and I got a
sense I got a chance to really take my
time with a grand hog oh so he's got a
[ __ ] hog oh so that Dwarfs both of
ours yeah no very impressive thick it's
thick he's the grand hug that hangs with
with with intention it hangs with with
bad intention dude how about like are we
getting each other gifts that she owes
yeah all right well would you get me is
it's in the mail to surprise you well
just name something you want man for
doing this and he
I like to be surprised [ __ ] your 36 [ __ ]
off
I like lies to me I'm like alright well
um what can you get him I don't know I'm
the I'm the worst with gifts man I want
cashmere sweaters I can slip on I don't
give a [ __ ] about anything else did you
get me
cashmere sweaters he gave me like real
friends don't get each other gifts
I agree more of a stress if I showed up
and you had a gift here
with tissue that's the way do you know
MJ gave me be annoying
I'd be so annoyed because I guess they
liked it you want now I got to add that
to the list I'm wearing the boots you
got me for my birthday birthdays were
different I expect to give some be I was
my 50th true that was milestone you know
it's a milestone
those are nice boots wait we were
talking about something that I wanted I
wanted to talk more about oh yeah
pumping your stupid face full of eggnog
this year I never said that you were so
glad to get back to LA after Buffalo
that you go I'm about to land I'm gonna
suck your fat dick when I was like dude
don't say I know you're excited but
don't don't threaten the suck on my day
I like to throw balls in there I know
but don't let the excitement turn you
hardcore gay yeah it's true yeah I just
get fired up you know you get fired I
like to get the most reaction I can't
have you that's what I do
that's why I send those my wife and my
kids know that I I'll come down if I
have a lot had a lot of sleep and I have
energy and everybody's having like a
quiet sweet time and I'm like somebody's
gonna get bit yeah it's - it's the
future looking control I got to squeeze
somebody to bite someone - I'm gonna
disrupt this whole situation yeah it's a
little too comfy quiet do you copy
and things are moving too slowly I gotta
ruin everything how about last night as
Joanna dot so you know everyone's The
Cribs just basically delirious at this
point no one's got sleep in about four
days not to the tiger and we're just
laying in bed pure quite can't have the
TV on because you know you don't want to
wake him up so we're just sitting there
and I got home for my set so it's like
your one o'clock at night she's so
exhausted she's annoyed cuz I've coming
through the back I don't want we tiger
up with the alarm so she had to wait up
for me I get that I can tell she's so
frustrated and she loves Christmas and
she's laying there the pillow over eyes
and pillows over my eyes it's complete
dark I go babe
you know what I want for Christmas she
goes why to go I want you to open that
grille and slam my [ __ ] head in there
she's like but she was all serious she's
old what and I go babe babe you don't
want for Christmas 20 minutes of [ __ ]
silence that's what I all I want she's
like okay got it I'm like babe babe you
know I want for Christmas she goes if
you don't shut the [ __ ] up with your
last one last one
you know I want for Christmas she just
want I went you and Tiger to get in that
car and just leave secured [ __ ] oh my
god that's the best thing I never tell
anything I want for Christmas I know
baby no of course like what
well you and Tigers skin that car go I
love [ __ ] like that
I love sick humor my son cuz I'm thirsty
don't get him water no water for you
don't you're not drinking water today
we're not having water today she gets so
mad woman don't say that to him I go why
you gotta toughen up you were wool dude
how about do you how about yesterday
where I take my kid for that play area
there when kids are out of school the
older kids come around which can be some
problem she's a little rougher you know
it goes but there's this Persian family
there it's kid with 16 months old gold
bracelets on each arm gold chains around
it's probably girl no no I don't know is
he's a boy sure positive talk to the dad
and the mom wearing bangles bangles
so I have to push them down gotta push
them probably get out of jewelry I'm in
you peacocking up in there yeah your son
be talking in here your son is
essentially the white Samoan yeah he
would go to Utah where all the Samoans
and Tongans
like boy they just did the boys are they
always talk about this boys and girls on
the playground the Samoan and tongue and
boys and girls before they've learned
how to well they're just dangerous they
just knock all the other little white oh
yeah yeah and your son would be just
dude you know how when you do him
tripley's show our boy from speed weed
he creates these like goodie bags I got
a bag bigger than that Lululemon bag
full of weed vape pens Kush oil all this
I mean I literally walk down like
dude I should probably sell this wheat
now let someone make money days I know
but there's a spray in there I'm like
man I need some sleep I need to [ __ ]
wind down and I've never used a spray at
the cinnamon spray I guess it's six
whatever milligrams of weed birthing so
I sprayed six sprays dude halfway
through the night I was so high the room
was spinning why oh my god really
because I usually do one like one here
the vapour spray it's like a matte but
like it's almost like an edible but it's
like it's like a mouse it's hash oil or
something it's the CBD
damn spray it's like a Simmons spray
dude I'm telling you I'm still groggy
you've got still groggy yeah oh my god
not good not almost too much for me my
mind my system the weed works for some
people for me if I do that if I get high
the night before I'm cloudy the next day
I'm just not all only if I do too much
and only if it's an edible vape it goes
away within like an hour but that you
know I'm actually teacher used to say
about alcohol like he'd been around
forever I mean he was a legendary
director a teacher taught everybody
everybody you can imagine and he said
his rule is if you have a job the next
day no alcohol for 24 hours I agree with
that yeah fighting I'm sure same way and
all that so my job because you you the
alcohol shown you some people need it
some people can be able to kill it on
their clothes I'm gonna be able to kill
it on weeds right cocaine I've just
never been that guy some people can get
no sleep and just rock I need sobriety
I just I'm - no I don't I don't yeah I
don't like I don't like where I go like
yeah I get to and I wonder if that
though is that is that being too
controlling and not liking to be out of
control cuz I feel like people that
don't mind being out of control who get
high don't fight it and just ride with
it so they're riding with it words I'm
trying to fight through it
no rogue is a control freak he's like
yeah that's true but I think they do
well with the it calmed him down
yeah he needs it it takes his air job
yeah yeah that's true never met anybody
more intense than Rogan before we never
in my life ever in my life ever
there's never never been anybody I've
met who was more intense
and if he chose to do something like if
a Logan picked up golf
you'd be pretty [ __ ] you to go well
he's already amazing it's like pool
archery like he's ridiculously good at
archery now of course and gave himself
like some kind of a repetitive injury
because he was pulling the bow back you
know fifteen hundred times a day they're
like you can't do that when he was
shooting a rifle I think they were like
look you're shooting that rifle so often
you're gonna get lead poisoning like we
comes obsessed with things you say
that's a video game no he can't play
video games if you did golf you'd never
seen if you're been obsessed with
something I'm not like that pledge not
like that
I like doing things but an obsessed no
no you know I I I get it enough I get
enough like of something stealing I'm
obsessed with his writing my stand-up so
it gets perfect and that dad I can spend
all day doing but that's different
that's yeah if that's more so Robbie
yeah not really
never well I go through a chance with
jujitsu and fighting for a while or is
that more so yeah yeah I mean it's uh
it's a destination it's a passion it's a
passion but I don't know if I'd say
upset right maybe a point there was
where I was with the with jiu-jitsu
really how much did you train at them at
the peak I mean standard it would
everyone does you know but I don't know
if I'd say I wouldn't go home and watch
videos and dream about it right like
some people are literally obsessed with
yeah like guys are obsessed with video
competition jiu-jitsu guys house yeah
but but take jiu-jitsu out of it like
everyone that there's guys that play
video games - I don't think that there's
guys who have died if you got to eat
certain personalities actually dopamine
in your brain that's a certain
personality trait yeah it's addictive
it's like some people some people get so
addicted addicted that they need a new
liver when they can't stop trying can
stop there's extremes on both ends of
the spectrum dude how about last time I
couldn't sleep I was on my phone
watching videos I saw a video of this
alligator crushing this poor turtle
I saw it you see it I sure did man I
sure as hell fascinating is they can't
do anything in accra alligator goes
I did those nobody can break through a
turtle horde a turtle shell yeah then
just do it was like nah boom like you're
great like it's a [ __ ] yes Thor chill
great like one of those Klondike bars
alligator crushing turtle they have the
American alligator has the strongest
jaws apparently no [ __ ] Brian in the
animal kingdom graphic footage yet for
your turtle
watch out turtle hey turtle how the [ __ ]
do not avoid that yes this is what about
that turtles like well how about the
eerie music warning shell breaking in
Lumbee you can hear that parental toe
screaming Oh Turtles like holy [ __ ]
about Oh
abort mission that's not him screaming
yeah that would be the giant they're
breaking or how long you got a deal with
it dude that's nature of diet good
turtle right there that's good it's a
turtle soup Oh turtle soup with some
blue you know what that is
what the peanut butter M&M for him yeah
that's a large shell peanut butter and
by the way his acid will laugh at that
show skittle hey real quick though
terrible way to go for a turtle I would
say so and and a person by the way well
person cuz that's what happens your bat
turtle is done done but also as a turtle
don't hang around the giant alligator
don't hang around the dinosaur now when
you see the dinosaur you gotta just go
under water and blend it with the mud I
watched that and then have you seen the
do you see the Sicario you've seen the
movie Sicario I know part 2 comes out
play that trailer check that [ __ ]
movie one of my favorite movies
yeah that's pretty oh oh what's there's
a fight just got done official trailer
this got me so crunk
remember does that soundtrack to it
the music's so goddamn good how would
you define terrorism [ __ ] around this
got me crunk last night what would be
able to play this [ __ ] I'll show a
little party baby
the music is so goddamn good at is the
soundtrack how much you love those guys
those two or you can legalize drugs
there how good was the version yeah
amazing or legalize it yeah and just
forget all this yeah or yeah or it's a
balls for y'all with all that mayhem
and all that shooting and legalize it
you know why cuz Americans and all the
rich Europeans love doing drugs so when
there's money it's gonna find its way
but that's a whole car where was it
where they legalized it in Switzerland
in Switzerland is that where they did it
needle Park they J when we were in
Buffalo he goes we talk about drugs with
the opening act and J goes yeah they
look legal legalize it and Switzerland
how good they're doing the guy goes what
having been there and jus no use I was
just there at chaos its chaos with chaos
he goes it's overwhelming man yeah at
certain parts that well Zurich has it as
a they disowned it and they have needle
exchange programs and all that health
care and everything yeah so again we
could how is that war on drugs going
there we've got movies let's make sure
I'm good word dude how about freaking
we're talking my last night that comes
to a TJ Miller keep sexual assault no
he's no from in when he was in college
his girlfriend in college
come on man okay that and then he has
show on coming since we got canceled no
yeah and then I don't proof or anything
there's cancel this [ __ ] porn star come
on
violent sexual
salt this is oh is this a new hot that
might be I know to Roberts the actor
that's a different one but for him a the
the thing up off started this was going
uh I mean cut high score yeah college
girlfriend he was in college at George
washer when we went [ __ ] man
and now so so they without any proof
writers no this is this is trial by
accusation this is unbelievable I mean
so so where is the like you tried a lot
of things without asking me and no point
asked me if I was alright I'm totally I
kept staring his fat heavy to say that
was afraid he's been saying he's
innocent for a long time to his friends
well so what the [ __ ] she's coming for
now and you cancel a show with no trial
I mean they're like straight-up dating
though right
he said sadly she is now using the
current climate to bandwagon and launch
these false I mean it's like you know
and now you're coming you know anybody
but he points them out here he goes
unfortunate that she's choosing this
route as its undermines the important
movement to make women feel safe coming
forward about legitimate claims against
real known predators yeah that's a good
point the problem is that you get this
kind of stuff and now you know networks
are so quick to just condemn somebody
it's like you know so she says I
attended George Washington University
from for undergraduate studies from 2000
till 2003 I drove a romantic
relationship with this women who spoke
with me about TJ Miller such assaulting
or just a bomb but yeah which crazy to
me is that time central like nope you
know animated series coming out and they
just that's to me outrageous this is
crazy it's outrageous that you just kid
all that work and all those people out
of work look man I mean let me did I
don't know if I mentioned this but
liking done over yeah much like ice
Prada I don't mean to rehash well it's a
bummer he's a friend of mine you know
it's like
at least have some due process let's say
that's where we're in a country of due
process you got to have evidence you've
got to have the super strange yeah Wow
not the Christmas gift you want if
you're TJ Miller not the Christmas gift
you wanted chin is there something you
want for Christmas in particular I don't
know everybody wants more money right
you just want to cash as a gift actually
that's a weird gift sir I don't
oh yeah freaking a nice camera did shoe
spy camera I mean a nicer one I've seen
in the past like gh five but haven't
seen the g8 one how much does G H five
with the lens part on like two thousand
five hundred this is the best camera in
the world it's just the one that a lot
of people like not the best one but oh
how good the one that you got I'm still
testing it but it's pretty cool
the focus sucks on it though so you know
like kid with this camera like the GoPro
if I just do this you're always in focus
yeah these guys it takes a while to like
get in there that's not good yeah so you
probably just use the GoPro at the shows
I'll use both really some angles yeah
[ __ ] UFO Jay what do you want
actually if anyone wants to help I'm
running a fundraiser on their Instagram
it's called army animals a ladies
dropping off at two o'clock blankets and
I'm right after this I'm driving to
Lancaster so if anyone wants to help
some puppies the county shelters are
really low on supplies for the bunny one
yeah donations and if not right we want
to raise some money for for the
injection that it takes to put them to
sleep
wait are you raising money for the for
supplies for them yeah for supplies cuz
they're low so right now I'm picking up
the first load and I'm driving from here
Lancaster and then there'll be one more
load where I'm gone but they're still
accepting donations apiece yeah
the animals what do you guys want I want
to buy trained German Shepherd you have
one I want a huge male with big balls
I want a wolf but you got a female yeah
I want to obedience to me and I want to
be able to set him I met I met the guy
who trained your Corgi Troy Conrad the
photographer at the Academy store his
girlfriend did does a show on the animal
planet with that yeah Nathan yeah yeah
yeah he was here Nate yeah yeah he's
really good with dogs man oh you want
that German Shepherd for Christmas
my dogs your wife gonna get you though
no I can't have three dogs that's had a
that's out of control
[ __ ] that I give one of my dogs away
trading they German they're gonna take
this hey drop something over there get
the turtle oh good fun get old snapper
so somebody loses their toes you lose
your toes oh my god snapping turtle my
dogs lose their paw or they're no no's
okay all day oh did today it's always
weird if you get a friend an animal for
a gift because how do you know they're
you know you don't want that they go
into
Todd Feldman's house right alright my
age it and he has these cats my girl
loves cats [ __ ] this oh my god loves
cats I'm allergic to him oh you are I'm
super allergic to him and when I was a
kid we had to get rid of him cuz so
allergic to him we went to the doctor
because my allergies were there all the
time my dad's like we just don't
understand like it's winter he has
allergies and the doctors do you have an
animal in the house my name is oh we did
just we had cats about a year goes it's
the cat he's let me do a little math
here two cats yeah
and then he's like anything else is
there anything else you guys me and he's
like cats get really cat yeah so we got
really ki be the cats I'm talking about
like every day my eyes would be swollen
shut like at my office Tara but I wanted
the cat so bad cuz an animal lover just
pretended of something else yeah and I
told Jo she won't believe me she's like
you're just full of [ __ ] you just don't
want to count like I'm telling you I'm
allergic so you know you're not like I
swear to God much to the cat should I
ignore you're not like all right I took
the cat rubbed his face way like this it
sure enough
my dinner looks like a gun either oh
gosh yeah I am I'm super allergic to me
I guess you can get a shot these days
though I guess my wife for your ballsack
yes my wife for years wood around
Christmas she would have the worst
allergies couldn't figure it out cuz it
was the Christmas tree pine my nails
look killer that's it and she's from
Denver yeah they're everywhere I know
that's interesting some sometimes trees
can cause some debris kavik I'm so lucky
I never suffered from Alan that's a
shitty animal no the most efficient
killers in the all the way oh yeah whoo
but cats are of shitty I'm so physically
gifted they can just their some way they
kind of suck though because like I was
telling Todd the stomach you know I
could take your cat and he would not
give a [ __ ] if you left your premises
they do not care Christ don't care hey
turn there's dogs that with their owners
die they sit by their grace so you can
tame a cat you can't domesticate a cat
that's never exactly like lions if a cat
was huge you know that your house cat
would be just as dangerous as a lion it
would eat you do with their claws with
everything you'd be so screwed yes they
are no joke
a big cat like a why there's even been
things where the owner died and the cat
ate the owners face off ah is that true
they were like oh we're starving you
didn't leave out the bowl of food guess
what amigo
you're all getting feel stupid face off
yeah thanks for all the mess we don't
thanks for the memories we don't care
about thanks for the memories your nose
tastes real chewy yeah cats are always I
don't know I've ever been a big cat guy
there's I wish we get up in the animals
chin a dog but it's my parents dog what
kind of dog remember a Korean Jindo
looks like Jin doesn't mean drunk
bingo that sounds looking at the dingoes
in Australia oh oh that's right Jindo
gate didn't forget their balance rhinos
what's up gene go that all about dingoes
Shindo gene no doc Jin does are actually
pretty good guard dogs and good hunting
dogs all using a hot pair you see big
dope these medium-sized yeah
medium-sized but they're fierce no fight
they're awesome show can you do me a
favor and me too
look ahead if we can Rogen posted a long
time ago a lion the jumps off a cliff
like jumps off a ledge and grabs a
wildebeest in or an antelope in midair
to show you how athletic they are it's
like oh my god no no no no the lion
jumps off the other it is right there
there it is right there leaping the
other one money
oh sorry which one see that one there
leave me break a channel over midair
attack watch this was big on Instagram a
lioness makes a very mid-air
interception of this flee an antelope in
a dramatic high-speed and wrestle how
about the lab though dodge in the first
one the first one this one was pretty
bad that's in front of a bunch of people
[Music]
windy out there huh yeah so they're just
waiting these of all the views to go
there you know in August I'm going to
see this really I'm gonna be right there
in August you can go to Africa yeah my
friends from Nairobi don't worry
you want to come watch them this is the
wildebeest migration oh [ __ ] that is so
fun I feel like I'm you know I need the
humans get more excited leave the peel
on the back the oh whoa
I'd be so [ __ ] crunk look at these
lines just waiting I would yell out
worldstar look at all the people just
sitting here watching these things this
is the migration you're watching the
migration boom
I think jumped over people be more fired
up about it maybe they've seen this like
this six times of they're gonna walk
over here sir please come over here sir
it's died over here huh you might want
the missus you might bother mrs. eat
your anus you're gonna die let's have
you die over here hey hey where you
trying to go pal hey why are people more
crumb hey come over here
oh you just put put up a fight you just
what you do is just suffocate the [ __ ]
sorry come over here for a second I
gotta suffocate you we are gonna kill
you over here in this grassy knoll and
then we're gonna eat you ask first if
you don't mind thank you so my my
missing coming rip your test guys I'm
gonna eat first everybody else go [ __ ]
themselves on the mail and then when you
guys are done you can scavenge for what
I left leave over thank you so much bad
men first he's fighting though holding
onto its its nose until it suffocates I
know all about lion the way Lions kill
because I'm a lion I'm a Leo right yeah
yes some Christian - what is this the
most random firing the kid of all time
it's good stuff slaughter in the water
all right mm he did an interview with
vulture magazine and the person asked
him do you ever use apps like tinder and
he giggles said yeah and grind her too
how about he said he's been kinder he
said that dating life is tough he goes
so here they go they go when you were
dating how did you meet people tinder
joking and eminem goes i mean yeah and
he goes you're being serious yeah tinder
he was really goes yeah and Grindr I
also used to go to strip clubs crying
for Gabe yeah yes transgender gay no
that's what everyone's wondering that is
[ __ ] around some people think he is
gay he's I don't think he's gay but
maybe Billy Eichner he's gay right hope
that Billy on the street guy he's joking
around he's very aware of what the [ __ ]
he's doing that's kind of a weird
interview though where I get dinner in
Grindr throw it out there [ __ ] I'd say
the same thing so would you use Grindr
leave it out there what seriously I
don't know you tell me
no with his lyrics you so anti
homophobic oh that's true that means
even more chance that he might be gay
yeah what's or sometimes we [ __ ] so
many girls like now it's a little dick
and they say that but that's how it
works I know a few people how that works
yeah yeah for sure
well you're like you know what let me
try some dong yeah hmm a buddy Jason
Ellis
oh yeah but Jason was probably always
you know I think he was sexualized by a
man at a young age for sure I mean I'm
tied up Ian said yeah so it's like I'm
not gay but I kind of sometimes it feels
good and you know that complicated thing
in the brain yeah can happen with Eminem
could've easily imagined this is a bad
one I think you guys were talking about
animals right now dogs and cats and I'm
sure you guys heard about this by now by
a woman who was killed by her two
pitbulls after taking him for a walk no
wasn't she killed in the woods by the
pitbulls so she walked him to the woods
right in the pit bulls girl no one saw
it so she went to the woods was gone her
father she was visiting her father at
that time too in a different area and
then she didn't come back for like over
a day and then when authorities came out
they saw two pit bulls just standing by
the body sort of guarding it so people
that
no her and the dog say that the dogs
would never do anything they love her
she raised him since they were puppies
all that stuff I spent there and they
smell foul play
then this that's what people were
thinking where'd he go detective Callen
yep but then the sheriff goes no well we
were there he was she was eating his her
rib cage the Bible was eating her rib
cage but he smell foul play I think the
dogs 100% did it damn cuz they were to
protect a head so there she was with
their father at the father's house and
the father actually had a nightmare she
didn't leave the dogs inside the house
they had him outside so they thought
that was one thing they'd neglected the
dogs a little bit so they they weren't
comfortable there okay but everything
else they weren't her dogs they were her
dogs she raised the two dogs herself
yeah and then found guarding her dead
body
the dogs weighed just about as much as
she does Wow yeah and he said it was an
absolute grizzly mauling yep he
describes a victim as very petite five
125 pounds the dogs themselves each
weighed about as much as Stevens [ __ ]
those are huge pit bulls Oh the first
traumatic injury was to her throat and
faced her she's taking the ground lost
consciousness and the dogs then mauled
her to death Christ Jesus Christ but
everyone's coming out saying it could be
something else it could be some horse a
pit bull that's why those much the next
guy but if you got a crazy pip on him
this side [ __ ] you I've had my whole
life I'm afraid of them oh me too
only because if I don't know the dog I
don't pet pit bulls Rottweilers no me
neither
I mean I know the reason I love them but
I don't if they're not mine I ain't
touched when they go nuts up I remember
trying to get a massive male dog off of
another dog and I had plenty of my own
dogs fighting with each other and I got
it out of that jujitsu choke where I
choked him but I before I learned that
there was a dog that just held on this
[ __ ] dog and I could not believe the
power
how are those pit bulls didn't say there
their jaws are crazy too they're beating
to tell me to go hurdle especially to
dogs
when I one of my best friends he has a
pit bull and it's the sweetest
friendliest dog ever
but I don't like to be alone with them
because it just feels like this guy
could kill me in any second and they
could yeah yeah it's like having a buddy
who's a felon before never really trust
them but they're cool you know I'll just
be honest you never you're always like
I'll probably I'll lend you money being
healed goddamn way that's like that dove
said dating an Eastern European
strippers kind of like owning a pit bull
you never really know where you stand
yeah okay Anees yeah yeah I also had pit
bulls my entire life it's uneasy for
sure their heads are so huge and massive
yeah some freak yeah they're so sweet of
a fight does break out in that dog park
yeah it's on yep they won the ones they
turn it on you're in some trouble
yeah well it's only bad news
she's pretty what the [ __ ] that first
ready I need me stopped using
Rottweilers the police start abusing
Rottweilers a while back along cuz when
they bite they do so much damage that
the lawsuits not worth it you need a
Malinois dog with no bite heart of
course but they kind of bite and hold on
control rot with that giant thick skull
when they bite down man it's horrifying
well it's good to UM it's a dark one
Floyd Mayweather Happy Holidays the UFC
you know that they're actually talking
Dana White said they're actually in
talks with Floyd Mayweather alright well
what is this keep going
um what's Dana White stay here we're
talking about doing the UFC deal white
told ESPN it's real he was talking about
boxing Conor McGregor was that real have
you heard Floyd talked about many things
that aren't real usually tips his hand
when he's in the media and that's how
[ __ ] ends up happening we're interested
in doing something with Floyd everything
is realistic possibility may other
McGregor [ __ ] could happen anything is
possible uh I don't know how serious
that is I know it's fun for them to talk
about it what talk about what a
nightmare if TFC were to sign him to a
fight deal just a you know it's like
he's got to know that he has the
wrestling and all that jujitsu well they
would give well they wouldn't give him
someone who's you know have wrestling
jujitsu be wait give him Conor Whitney
no oh they give him some of the odds
alright
come on man keep up ya know the night
game karma good they give me who knows
something that no one we know they give
them someone who just box a little then
I can give him a wrestler Jessica it
ain't happening tell you that right now
it's not happening that would be career
suicide for the UFC yeah career suicide
you open up the floodgates no one takes
you seriously anymore no one's investing
in your in your business that'd be a
nightmare
yeah that's not real I call [ __ ]
what else you got
it's fun to keep Damon Floyd in the
headlines for that I call [ __ ]
alright next one is a Pizza Hut so
called pizza story a pizza delivery
driver got a call from one of the one of
the people - I ordered pizza and the guy
that called said can you make a joke and
you put a joke inside the box so she did
put a joke in there and it says what do
pizza delivery driver and a gynecologist
have in common and then she wrote they
both have to smell it but neither of
them can get to eat it oh and she got
fired so I fired you the last one yeah
we're we're humorless awesome yeah fire
somebody who's got a job that's great
everyone some more joke now you're a
[ __ ] that customers a [ __ ]
the customers [ __ ] you customer but the
customers mom but also Pete sake should
also pizza it sucks compared to Domino's
they do Pete's I cannot hang [ __ ] you
Pizza Hut yeah I don't know what was she
gonna do I need lots of career guesses
for pizza girl and I agree shame on you
be total Papa's Papa John's or Domino's
you know what Domino's really has the
market yeah I really got it cornered
they make a nice
here's da menos dama here's a little
thing free if you want fresh beats from
diamonds you'll make sure you get the
old one ask for extra robust tomato
sauce cuz they can't just put it on
their robots yeah then you know it's
fresh I want to get Pizza Hut now I
can't I found my diet haven't cheese yet
either
that's a maze lightheaded but that
McDonald this is some fat [ __ ] i
mcdonald's fremont fresh fries asked for
unsalted fries and they have to make a
fresh battery really yep any other
brain-busters fat kids unsalted how is
it so how is unsalted fries they're
delicious oh bus they're delicious
because you'll put your own [ __ ] soul
on the chin but
fresh so extra of this extra I don't
like sauce tomato sauce yeah yes for
extra robust tomato sauce I'm getting it
because they can't be like oh [ __ ] just
giving that old one toss sauce
underneath nah can't do that you have to
make a fresh pizza and it is so fresh my
mouth is watering so hard right now you
would you eat a whole pizza I mean a
whole Domino's pizza right now easily
and throw up afterwards you would write
haven't had carved in forever I've even
had a cheap meal sense you're making me
angry right not a cheat meal Sen ever
you bugging me
sorry bro oh there's me I like being on
a diet man I know you do you like to be
all skinny and shredded like being I
like to walk around a trim 2:49
tomorrow's gonna be tough at this gonna
stick to the diet let's bring some
snacks snacks what do you figure you
weigh right now getting on getting down
to 205 would be quite simply impossible
for you you're not able to do it I mean
what we might as well talk about you
making 145 my job or fighting who cares
well I do cuz I might start I don't know
what I am I don't know what am i way
myself want no not now
I started off 250 for sure for sure
that's a good like that's a weight you
carry very easily yeah I don't know man
like being on diet though kilos [ __ ]
eased and I mentioned a videotape myself
trying to do 200 pounds on the bench you
can't with fewer events
I couldn't bench 200 pounds and I'm
super sore because I did a whole workout
yesterday and oh well how much you weigh
I'm 170 there's no excuse it's very sad
that I can't do 200 pounds once I am NOT
a strong think the average male I think
the average look up the average bench
for males in the United States I think
it's 135 well I'm a [ __ ] and I'm
outraged I will get 200 pounds I just
have never I never lifted I was never
alone Oh a bad man you sure yeah I know
teenagers we can do that right now I do
too 165 pounds is the bench of 80 pairs
so it would say let's go into this the
average I saw this unknown man smells it
yeah fall in the pram I get 250 pretty
soon
400 the standards 135 there you go
135 the standard jumps up to 175 if
you're I'll be at 215 sir yeah and what
I'm I just do what should really focus
on increasing your bench well now I
focus on my hand clean in Miami clean -
Emma squat and squat because it's not
acceptable that that I I put 176 exactly
on the unmess and that after five reps I
I'm I must stop did you do it you have
no I did it with my mic my coach Josh at
Venice barbell club dude did you fire
months but no he giggles because he's
five seven and two hundred and thirty
pounds
it'll be some girls who can I mean I
trained with that I trained with them
I'm oh you mean
you mean the girls that are competitive
that I I'm working out right next to the
three other hot CrossFitters who make me
look like an [ __ ] like an [ __ ]
yeah no I'm very I'm very where is not
for you men well I'm not a strong man
running and that's I don't like saying
it but I just don't have the bone
structure to move a lot of weight the
Popish I'll [ __ ] you up in that bed I'm
not slow I'm pretty athletic light on my
feet it's not strong just not strong I
can get the body of a praying mantis
yeah I would like to say I can hit hard
because I hit mitts but the truth is I
can't do that either can I rent it I
can't hit hard
yeah athletic though I'll give you a
Matthew athletic I'm athletic
I've always been athletic you know
strong pretty fast yeah yeah and wise
yeah but not strong I know I can shrug
it off but TRT trt and really applying
myself
ask your trainer go hey bruh I know I
can't lift 135 but if I get on TRT how
much think I can do in a month see what
he says well we're gonna see cuz I'm
gonna shoot my ass up I don't see you
ever doing that well you'd be surprised
because I might go talk to an
endocrinologist you gonna do
I feel though that I have so much energy
and my energy I know the way honey dick
Ulis you gonna do it or not maybe I will
just start soon they all veined up I'll
tell you one thing if I do do it
everybody's gonna know about it I ain't
keeping it a secret
no we're not gonna be one of those guys
who's like what I've got an arm just
muscular [ __ ] off
no hell no I'll advertise that [ __ ] all
video Tichina have you ever tried to max
out on benchpress when I was younger
would you get to what is 2:45 is in a 25
that's two on each side beside 275 yeah
yeah wait wait
I've done three 340 files on each side
to 3:15
what is that 315 yeah with the bar for a
damn shoulder oh my god dude I was big
you taught was this when you were like
the factory in between fat into getting
lean that's when I was like this guy I
used to meet headed out in the in the
not like you guys I like I like the
weightlifting cuz it I like keeping
myself super honest like you can walk
around yourself in the taking your seat
a and then you have you then you have to
do the bar with that weight and you go
oh no my mole bone structures built for
ballet I'm built from Bali I'm built for
ballet not war Bali well spill from Bali
squat that squat is something you gotta
practice that doesn't mean you can't do
it yeah well we're gonna be surprised
we're gonna see if bribry can get some
tea or tea well we're just gonna see
what Brad Brad can do if he starts
applying himself to some weightlifting
do that focus on that dude that's more
than 50 you think so so I can pop
something I do all you me fit you on
January you should all your attention
forget your special Netflix just focus
on the bench
okay well also what about the snatch and
hang clean I was too concerned about
that okay because even people specialize
that aren't you concerned about that and
hi
that's crazy chin you're strong man hey
man still strong
no no you know you don't worry know
what's funny people always ask if Brian
could take me in like wrestling or
fighting or something they always ask
that really yeah
those are weird questions very well
don't to stop do you know I'm like what
ten years younger I think I'm very big
dude background check window when I was
a kid well yeah so does Callan ya know
what and I still spar and I fight guys
with a lot younger than me we're not
doing fun you don't
you don't fight no but I punch dudes in
the face I'm down to do with Brian
Fuentes bar Oh seriously if you if you
really feel like you could take me that
I have to do so much good charity if you
want to put on headgear and gloves I
don't want to hurt you
I don't come down to just bossing I will
I'm gonna will do that and I will move
around I would be super super I would be
actually really interested in that just
to see how it's in I will do I could
train chin Brian and you stay with Wayne
okay
Brian has been training a lot so I know
he's gonna be good but you've never done
it have you ever been in a ring but I
fought I fought
what a mean fought like fought just
fight people growing up and yeah yeah
but that's a little bit different right
I don't know you know will do because I
don't like this kind of stuff because
that's how people get like you get
cracked or something else yeah but we
just come down and put on headgear in a
mouthpiece and move around let's see
what happens I'm done okay that's like a
fun workout yeah for sure that'd be
great don't say move around though like
you know what you're doing don't don't
say move around cuz you don't know [ __ ]
about physics well I'm real quick hold
on I know waiting on the minutes things
huh you guys are all high sparked a lot
listen dude we'll move around right no
no this is what's gonna happen shouldn't
even come down there if you think you
bench in 1/35 was sad I said IB that's
almost 200 percent hasn't fought and for
every beat the [ __ ] out I'm gonna take
them on my wages here you beat the new
rage 10 listen man I don't I don't think
you would destroy Chen well I think you
got your hands full
she's a big kid yeah box with some much
bigger guys than him though I know that
I know that you have waiting you corner
a Hollywood ad say what tell you what
buddy move around
we'll do it at boxing burn though yeah
we're just come no doubt that you're
good though I'm not good at all the
boxing isn't money at least I'm Way
better than what I'm saying is that what
I'm saying is that um sometimes you get
you get really tired right so if you
start getting hit in the stomach
yeah it's even a little bit like if you
haven't done it you get winded quick
like it's really what I'm saying to you
after watching millions of rounds of
boxing yeah you're not going
out [ __ ] point chin what's gonna
happen since he doesn't have any boxing
experience he's gonna close the distance
she is gonna be like this the entire
round that's what's gonna happen oh hey
before you say that I don't pay and take
five pounds of mini I look at me in the
eye yeah if I had to bet yeah and you
guys go three rounds yeah my head's
gonna be a toss-up my hands are getting
hot let me talk so I mean look at me
chin would need to be counter is a
toss-up we have to do this now bras a
must dirty we ought to do a Fight Night
[ __ ] Allen fight no we don't hurt each
other so just come down just move no no
no stop that stop let me come down and
before we do that please let me show you
just why would you do that then there's
no one wants to let me know because I
don't can you get nervous no no I get no
satisfaction out of going our chin
thinks he can beat me now I'm gonna
[ __ ] jab him and hit him as hard as I
can
after I've been training like that's all
I do I feel like if I that's all you do
like if I do that then we're not you
want another real truth you want you
were here to guy the other you know I
have heard I mean I heard him and I said
I hate I felt bad I hate I feel bad too
that's why I do this is why this is
gonna work I think you're gonna be
surprised that you're not Floyd
Mayweather and he's gonna be surprised
but whatever your move rise dad because
he doesn't fight you really surprised
that you box all this time in your I can
outclass look I think my I'll be good
Jim let me see let me see you throw up
just a one-two right now stand up for
say a one two yeah let me see you throw
up you're gonna take his box let me just
see something yeah how do you stand how
do you stand good can you throw a little
faster okay so can you can you just show
me like a jab just jab jab they can't
hear this thank you missing yeah alright
okay good you Basin off that have you
been in a ring here within a tree and
then boxed I've had I've messed around
but now like okay I've never been
trained so just come down no no we're
gonna do this you're gonna come down
first before we do that and I'll just
move around just
just just whatever and then you try to
hit me and we'll see what happens but
I'm gonna be there we're gonna film it
you can be there if you want but the
problem with filming is I'm gonna hit
him if you do that you're this is what's
gonna happen you're feeling it hurt
because it's gonna be better fight than
you think
I don't think so it'd be like wrestling
like like even with me like wrestling
jujitsu wise if we really roll like I
haven't rolled in a long time wait so
wrestling would be a different animal
wrestling be a different animal oh so
you're saying that not though you know
me and Brian wrestled so Brian would
destroy me wrestling wrestling yeah
wrestling's a lot more technique Brian
does have experience in that boxing you
can make it a [ __ ] show where you can
even if it doesn't matter but also an
today but also when you pay a trainer
and you're in there you get a false
sense that you can box everyone does
this I've seen it happen oh yeah let me
see you shadow box and he thinks he
knows boxing I couldn't tell boxing I
can't tell you but that's not because
Tonia's you're in here acting like I I'm
saying I can Bob you are when you said
come down we'll do it first now I had
too much respect for Bob no he's saying
we show when we spar like so - if I go
in with a guy who's never boxed exactly
or maybe he's like head you know I don't
know he's been boxing for four months so
what will happen and you know this if
you've been doing it for a while you can
see what he's gonna do right sometimes
their heads attenders slow does it make
sense for me to punch the dude in the
face really hard no so I'll move around
so he feels comfortable right like
anything else so if I'm moving with a
really good guy like I move with this
guy who's like took the second [ __ ]
silver medal in the world now he's
bigger he's not gonna beat me up he's
moving around with me because he knows
[ __ ] and I'm [ __ ] hitting him and I'm
closing in and I'm and I'm wrestling and
trying it and with he's kind of giggling
and stuff like that that would be him
moving around with me right and guess
what chin saying I'm a good [ __ ] but you
move around he says I can be - in boxing
no I'm not saying that however that's
what you said I didn't say I would be
you said your subproblems and I was the
most lying over you I'm surprised that
people think that like are off the bat
really yes it's surprising also you said
wrestling rest
you said he would definitely destroy yes
wrestling we're not really hurting each
other so we should also wrestle to see
if you can actually bet that by the way
when I say wrestle not like like there's
no just to see who has control for a
little while and then let go you know
I'm saying oh yeah you know boxing is
actually boxing for me is tricky to
write because it is true like when
wrestling you can like move around you
don't get hurt
boxing like just getting hit can [ __ ]
hurt but you know like like like you
maybe not for you but for the right
Irish guy getting caught in the back of
the head like yesterday I docked and I
got caught in it [ __ ] like I was like
whoa even with headgear it's not that
fun sometimes you know it's fun to do it
but not yeah really like certainly gyms
will you go like you'll see these guys
like getting in the ring with some dude
is a good amateur doesn't know you for
me at 50 no no cuz he's got to know that
I'm you know sounds like you guys are
gonna have a marathon he wants to
wrestle you
let's box alright now we need a third
thing we have a foot radius you would
definitely be mean but I mean I think I
can battle wrestling I don't know why I
feel like a stick not like win a match
but actually you to the point where have
you my power played around with it it's
interesting I understand why you that's
why I should that's why I should do it
just to get on yeah but I'll say this
never we need a third one though so
boxing wrestling then the third he
doesn't have let's say Gibby Korean a
high let's say for whatever reason you
beat Brian and boxing right let's say
we've made you the overall winner just
cuz the [ __ ] show and then Brian beat
you and wrestling we need a third one
can't even flip [ __ ] can't be
wrestling and we can't be a farmer
locking oh no that doesn't power things
I doesn't count
that's what MJ said thumb wrestling but
I just took it or not further and I'm
not very secure about basketball I feel
like you both suck your battle I can't
even dribble dude well brides off - what
about no jennife tennis so destroying
tennis yeah I've never I can't hit a
fastball could go to the batting cage I
don't
yeah suck at baseball that would just be
a [ __ ] show for everyone
a big golf to coordinated to smooth to
smooth too much up top Dolph doesn't
count too much of it touch
I smelled Oh skill um barely got out
there no huh gets both to take one
though yeah what else could we do
I think arm wrestling's number one it's
the safest you think it's fun
I think softwraps well I think sprint
sprint sprint I'm so fast dude we known
for your speed when you're growing on
now no okay neither was I so we should
probably do that now I'm not known for
anything like that
good high school wrestling you've ever
met
yeah is athletic well Jim's just a big
guy it's a lot of move it's a lot of
body to move around boxing and wrestling
so it'll be fun
hey chin I say we sprint chin look at me
yeah that pisses me off see that bums me
out
that's not regen I don't I know guys are
really your Boston Oh Tucker you got a
hand on the box and burn I'm with coach
chin you you go get coach but look at me
come down first a little primer and then
go train with Brendan
no no why would he give away his tools
so got no tools right now me my boxing
with three years bro threes my language
three years I said to Bret and I go yeah
I think I'm getting this like it was
Mara like about a year ago I think I'm
getting this guy learned at least for
you like this yeah dude yeah so so make
sure that you train like that for 10
years and still not get it boxing is
[ __ ] impossible really hard well
that's what you guys gonna do boss
wrestle off and he's in serious shape I
haven't lifted weights in years I did
push up yeah that's it that the one
thing that I can't boxing so exhausting
you gotta shape you know what shouldn't
as the I don't give a [ __ ] attitude I
know okay can't wait
we'll make a shirt for it film it too
yeah we're gonna do it like a [ __ ]
cool like wob stealthy I'm sure it's
gonna be sick maybe let's do that on it
yeah maybe I'll get on it involved yeah
all right what if Bryan knocked
you know I would never that's it there I
think he would have checked you out
but if should knock you I would never
like try to hit him super never know
just fever wings on wild and kaduche I
wish he would be so I get no pleasure of
that I don't like that [ __ ] I'm terrible
Brian so much I wouldn't want to I would
get no satisfaction Oh chin hasn't boxed
ever and all this I'd do something
ragged like that and you get and you put
your glove down and I catch you and
awesome yeah look at that
well mover I think the reason I don't
light it is because there's so many
dudes that could do that like it's all
levels to the game all levels well we'll
see what happens guys I wish you both
the best I can't pick sides here I wish
you both the best in Switzerland all yes
I'm gonna be the narrator on the ref oh
I'm the organizer I'm the promoter all
right I'm Dana White here okay Bob Arum
couch in 2018 my wife was hauling so
[ __ ] hard at Bobby Lee when he was
calling she talkin move the column he's
going racist see the way he's [ __ ]
hilarious he's just sitting there with
his feet I need a thing like a [ __ ]
aging guard girl just all up on my chair
what else you got to know what you know
here let me just leave you with this you
never know you never know I read this
fascinatingly but leave us with this not
ending no I'm not but I was about this
conversation this designer his name is
uh like Richard Skillman is a designer
and an engineer and he [ __ ] did this
experiment where he had you get a yard
of transparent tape you get twenty six
pieces of uncooked spaghetti you get a
string like a like you get a yard of
string the yellow yarn of yarn and you
get a marshmallow
all right now you have to build the
tallest structure possible and the only
rule is that the marshmallow has to be
on top okay okay all right so you get
six thousand pieces over twenty six
pieces of uncooked spaghetti let me say
it again
a yard of transparent tape one yard of
string and a marshmallow okay
he had fork he broke
he did this experiment over all
different groups but there's gonna blow
your mind he had four different like you
had four teams of four business school
people CEOs lawyers and kindergarteners
okay build a tallest structure who wins
kindergarteners why kids they don't they
don't have any ceilings don't have any
expectation this did what they want to
do it that's close
like CEOs got 22 inches kindergartners
26 inches [ __ ] business school
students 11 inches not creative lawyers
15 inches because what happens is they
say that adults will break into lwe
analytical but they break in a silent
status groups like they don't want to
say something because they might get
criticized and it breaks into this sort
of one guys the natural alpha louder
speaker more opinionated kids or just
like they don't speak they're all
together like no let me try a million
different right million things it
doesn't matter and they just finally
they make this [ __ ] crazy thing and
at this book I'm reading called the
talent code I'm sorry the culture code
by this guy Dan Coyle about how why does
certain groups do better he [ __ ]
study Navy SEALs and even jewel thieves
there were these really really high-end
really successful team of jewel thieves
and he studied like what the culture was
essentially it's like they were all even
within the jewel piece they were all
safe to come up with ideas that might
suck they were there was no they were
allowed to be vulnerable what if this
idea goes yeah they're like why don't we
try this idea when they would plan [ __ ]
out yeah and sand all the the
high-ranking military guys and like like
an improv troupe that's really
successful Oh a championship basketball
team I don't remember who it was but
it's really interesting that he would
draw through lines to all these like
successful yeah like culture culture
successful cultures and versus
unsuccessful cultures and one dude if
one dude he put they do these swears
would have a slacker a guy come in he
played a slacker he played the or he'd
play the disruptor like he or he play
the another another guy who would just
be lazy and you know whatever he'd be a
the downer downer and that tube would
bring the
whole [ __ ] group down he put his head
down he just put his head down like this
and then like I'm bored and pre-student
three other people yeah yeah and but
then there was always one group but
there was one dude he had curly hair and
he was this kind of skinny guy and he
never let that guy disrupt him that guy
would just he somehow would defuse the
situation he'd smile at the guy and be
like that's good what do you think
include him before this guy knew he was
after trying to the guy [ __ ] the guy
before I knew it he was actually helping
any key was supposed to not nothing
worse than negative nancies
nothing nothing work there's a way to
defuse it he talks about in the book but
be a wild man interesting little sketch
in I'm hoping Brian can school us with
this the tax bill that just passed
Senate yeah do you know much about this
Brian good for middle right I don't know
enough because every time I read about
it there are different points if you
want it I know that there is talk unless
you're grandfathered in you're not able
to write off more than ten thousand
dollars of your mortgage Thessaly not
Herbie doesn't it helps out the most the
big corporations and then the really
wealth like the one percent of them okay
so the reason that you want to lower
corporate taxes as the argument goes is
that we have some of the highest
corporate taxes in the world and so when
you tax corporations a high amount what
happens is they go to other countries
because taxes are nil or very small like
Apple right Apple went to Ireland like
that so you don't want that so you want
to create incentives for corporations
that hire million lollipop we keep it
local I came here yeah and so you got to
have a tax plan that is competitive
globally so that would be the idea
behind that that I so look at so let's
see the House passed the massive 1.5
trillion tax packages that affects
everyone's taxes but is dominated by
breaks for business and higher earners
okay let me let me just say that
something higher earners weird though
yeah what's the what's the let me let me
say something about higher on you scroll
down or two things about that when you
hear about the 1% guys keep this in mind
okay let's just listen to this for a sec
then 1% is not a fixed group of people
there are people going in and out of the
1% all the time okay
second of all keep this in mind the top
tax earners pay far more of their of the
Rev tax revenue the neighbor pay 85
percent of
correct so top tax earns also pay a
shitload in taxes you have to remember
that they make up 85% of correct and
that's that's something that is that is
always lost in the debate and oh and oh
by the way please keep in mind that a
reason a lot of people make money a lot
in this economy is because they put up
provide goods and services that we all
buy keeps girl that we want whether it's
comedy whether it's gadgets whether it's
iPhones whatever it might be
keep going so there have been a lot of
customers starting next year families
making between 50 to 75 thousand we're
getting average tax cuts of $890
according to the analysis by the
nonpartisan Tax Policy Center families
making between 100 to 200 thousand we
get an average tax cuts of $2,000
well families making more than 1 million
would get an average tax hits of nearly
$70,000 but they're paying more in tax
their payment right let's see but if
that customers are allowed to expire
most American those making less than
75,000 would see tax increases in 2027
and that's the thing that's the thing
that I worry about too is statistics are
very tricky you know that there's that
great saying statistics are like a
bikini what they reveal is interesting
what they hide is is significant you
know that that idea so it's not the
whole story
and Schumer's so so Schumer is a a
liberal lion a classic liberal New
Yorker who is always favored higher
taxes especially on the wealthy there's
a there's a there's a an idea that when
you tax the wealth we need to tax the
wealthy tax the rich and give it to the
poor that's such an old played out way
it's not a very creative way but you
hear a lot of liberals talking that way
and there's got to be a better way
that's just got to because when you tax
the people that produced you tax a lot
of the wealthy what happens Eve is they
leave where they stop producing I had a
conversation with a [ __ ] um a very
smart professor and I said what do you
want to do tax my friend 80 percent he
goes well yeah look it's kind of maybe I
go you're a communist we had a whole
conversation about that like you might
be very smart about being cooperative as
a comic country but not when somebody is
forcing me to spend work I don't want to
work I
work fifty percent of my day is bent
working for the government fifty percent
I spent at least that much in taxes
right I see half my money fifty percent
I'm good with that
that's cool the government doesn't do a
good job of distributing it all right
what else your chin this is just an
update on that one
you have faux stuff oh well basically oh
it's right there Tom DeLonge you know
the guy that was on Rogen's podcast yeah
182 he was apparently in some of these
released
you know leaked emails with Hillary
Clinton talking about the US UFO stuff
he was hitting on his name was in those
emails shooting and he released those
did you hear my robe you know I was
insane what he said well now it's not so
insane that it's kind of true he was
just saying how he's working with the
government and there's aliens and he's
funding this project and he's the rich
guy uh he's from blink away too but he
has Richard from but he was saying all
this stuff about how he's working with
the government and they meet him in
these high-level places and he's talking
about all this UFO stuff and I'm like
god this guy's falling off the wagon and
Ron goes why would they work with you
out of anyone in the world he's like I
don't know man they reached out to me
and it sounds like he's completely full
of [ __ ] but now there's emails of him
and Hillary Clinton that's what my name
was yeah and then he released these two
pieces of footage he did we caught
Declassified footage but one of them
wasn't always already which is the other
one this is yellow one which is hard to
I saw this it's hard to watch this to
see this stuff though cool but they kind
of explain it here in this video
fans be able to see nothing actually we
should probably talk about just release
all of it like come on YouTube site is
called to the stars Academy of Arts in
science and that's Tom de lodge's
company yeah correct
so it's ours Academy of Arts and Science
I'll just cut this part out so it's not
super long and this is just telling you
how to read these different little
markers on them that's kind of tough to
follow we keep going sensor as is aimed
four percent to the right since they're
zoom 1.0 this I'm glad they're breaking
this down layman terms censured aim six
degrees above aircraft access
f18 calibrated airspeed 225 kilometers
match Mach number 0.55 this display
doesn't matter is a white mode
yeah Hiram's Oh got it : to black thank
god they're doing this that's an F /a 18
altitude 19900 watch yourself
[Music]
tell me it's just not that [ __ ] dot
in the middle right now weapon sensor
operator changing the zoom so it changes
TV mode pilots 9 o'clock TV mode
object appears dark gets bright daytime
sky fully why wouldn't you be able to
see it better why is it so bright you
tell me that's not too good year blimp
maybe that's expensive right that could
be there I feel like my iPhone could get
better comfort but just one where the
thing is rotating have you seen that
yeah no I'm old I'm a boxer so my head
gets all [ __ ] up so it's moving
rapidly right now that's not very blimp
ish is it this is like when Chad showed
me the picture of the ghost and I was
the guy that came out and came back and
look to me looks like a guy I'm sorry it
was probably some grip who was camera I
would just like some you think after all
the technology would have some sort of
legit picture this is [ __ ] this is a
waste of my goddamn look look how fast
it goes to the left boom damn I'm not a
roach on the screen big deal screen he's
part of this thing crazy as hell but
he's actually part of this stuff he's
releasing so all you can do when you
soon as you go like this huh that's
weird and then we all go no one can
defend it no one can argue watch it some
more I guess I'm already bored I'm not
already bored literally everyone goes
but even at risk oh yeah hmm yeah it
could be because you can't explain
something doesn't mean there's no way
that's all that photographer columns
like this validates some of his
craziness good for him what else get you
for sure have better pictures of UFOs
now one more it's just another teacher
or the student her she's a Christian
school teacher and she was caught with a
15 year old boy by her husband Oh No and
then she's arrested because he reported
her come on did the husband beat up the
youngster set of eyes on her and I think
she was caught when the boy was already
like a couple years older but they
started their relationship when he was
15 15
Accio 17 it's kind of hot
so you just walked in when you're 15 16
17 is a boy you're a walking hard-on see
right there
andrea has always felt called to work
with youth and is very excited that God
opened the door for her to be a part of
the logos team God you know that dick
maybe maybe somebody like this is
attractive to youth because they're
drawn to they're sexually drawn to yeah
I mean it's usually I might say well the
Santos is a moment when it's a man I'm
always ago but maybe it exists with
women too man javi said yeah yeah so is
that it chin that's pretty much it and
also that Amtrak thing I think they the
three things I think right now is that
it was obviously going 50 miles per hour
faster than it should've on that curve
81 miles an hour
yikes and then there there might have
been some object placed on the on the
rail accident yeah on the on the track
something was placed there they think
like they like to buy things on purpose
cuz [ __ ] it's a it's super hot I've
always wondered why that doesn't happen
more often
mmm like you know like put a bowling
ball or a [ __ ] anvil dude why not
when I get on the train there's no
security
there's no no I went oh no no wonder New
York you mean Isis I'm Proms like you
literally I was like nothing I just have
this thing a lot of the a lot of the
intelligence work goes on like you know
behind this game yeah listening to
people before when I saw Flanders damn
right there's not a whole lot of
security through the old tracks yeah oh
[ __ ] did you know these nuts in your
mouth
I won't let's see it's reddit Jim I
think that's it yeah
all right girls are interesting man cool
those were interesting well I wish
everyone a happy holiday I wish
everybody a happy holiday and I think we
should do for the guests see cuz by time
to come back will be 2018 that's right
buddy so we're just gonna let you guys
vote for guest of the year we'll do on
t5k Tom I have J shot put up a poll on
there you guys vote for against year we
don't want to pick we don't you guys
vote on their one out
when we come back from the break mm-hm
but yeah next week there will be no
friend the kids no no no dark sometimes
we go dark I got some sad news man
everybody we're gonna we're gonna go
dark next week
whoa not not like not like freakin 0.30
dark we're not going dark dark so
there's still gonna be an episode
there's you mean abso sir
what do you mean when you have some kind
of a Christmas surprise in store for
everybody it's the gift that keeps on
giving
what were you happy we're gonna blend
together the best guest of the year make
one so super apis so we have the best of
the best of you might get feel Vaughn
you regular Chris D'Elia
okay Hinchcliffe little judd apatow wow
yeah you getting it at all Wow yeah
we're doing all that stuff hits great
it's called The Greatest Hits
jingle-jingle
thank God for Greatest Hits
jingle-jingle [ __ ] all right cut it's
his channel Ginga [ __ ] your college got
a whole lot better a whole lot better
muhfuckas she's less even we need a
vacation sometimes we need a bridge take
a week a year some we love you guys do
we thank you for everything thank you
she had a great year Chinn MJ thank you
guys have been graced with a good year
another good year the books for his bus
right buddy all right what about my pal
yeah more to come when skin started we
are we gonna be Grail men I already a.m.
well you are I'll get there one day bro
that's right where can they find 1418
they'll be glad you asked buddy well I
want you guys to come out to see me in
Nashville at Zanies
January 12 13 14 with my favorites blood
and then I want you to come out to the
funny bone in Columbus January 25 26 my
birthday 27 you welcome all right are
you well - welcome I told them yeah well
yeah and I'm reverting back my Eisenmann
be 49 I keep getting every 51 I know you
be 51 Ohio go see Brian County in Ohio
they hit the home it store that you'd
love those shirts really that's yeah
right next to the club everybody I'll
set you up with those guys for me Boston
there 12 tickets left I check every
morning there are 12 tickets left to the
Wilbur theater is sold out January 19th
special guests open up that [ __ ] but
before that Portland the helium of the
11th through the 13th I'm in Portland
Boston tonight
teams and then I had
of Denver I'm coming home February first
then the second through the third on the
st. Louis for Brian and myself get
tickets at T fat K dark con-com we love
you guys
Happy Holidays Merry Christmas well I'm
behind why I'm Happy Hanukkah all of
that every Sarah wanza whatever man
happy Holi Wiccan day this is the fire
kid we're out